[Music]
pictures up are you ready
yep
action
[Music]
hi there
hi
what is your date of birth 27th of april
1999. do you know what you're here for
yes
go ahead tell us about yourself i want
to be the best
no
not the leg no the foot can open the
knee all right elbows like this
and then for the butt shot
guys look at you you got a little butt
on you
are you ready to make a banana happy oh
my god
just give me a little tap and that means
like chill out yeah she definitely can't
have you
i found my niece like i'm very
submissive
oh the wine glasses all the time
i'm gonna take over this [ __ ]
don't you want to see anything else in
la besides a porn set
no
what really drew you out here
this is a long way from home
hello him
i'm just out here because i wanna
this is your life
you spoke without agent you're the one
in charge what if i would do it for free
and when you really want something
you can do anything
[Music]
everybody's gonna want to be booking you
for crazier and crazier [ __ ]
[Music]
i love being in front of the camera i
love having people watching me
look at me
i'm here to be the next big porn star
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you